how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel today we have
some very interesting news about Emily
Blunt now Emily Blunt has been very
popular in the Marvel fandom over the
past few years fans really really want
her in the MCU she was a very popular
fan cast Ford Captain Marvel now
obviously she didn't get that role it
went to brie Larson but lately she's
been the most popular female fan cast
for Sue Storm The Invisible Woman and
not to mention everybody has wanted John
Krasinski to play mr. fantastic
alongside her this would be an awesome
scenario as they are married in real
life and could be a couple in the MCU as
well and not to mention John Krasinski
has become pretty popular himself with
most of the Fantastic Four fan art being
of him and his wife Emily Blunt if
you've been on YouTube in the past a
year you've most likely seen a picture
of her as Sue Storm of course it's fan
art but you've seen it and I'll most
likely put it in the thumbnail of this
video as well that's how popular she's
been but it looks like fans may end up
getting what they want it's been
reported that Emily Blunt has met with
Disney and Marvel Studios about an
upcoming role in an upcoming movie set
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so she
may be on her way to the MCU well break
it all down in this video but first be
sure to subscribe with notifications
turned on so you don't miss anything
that's relating to the MCU I'm also
giving away a Captain America shield in
just one day on my other channel cosmic
culture if you'd like to enter head over
there and subscribe to the channel and
comment on the most recent videos we'll
be picking a random winner from the
comments section and again that ends
tomorrow so this report that Emily Blunt
met with Marvel Studios comes from
Charles Murphy at Murphy's multiverse
calm you've probably heard his name as
he's leaked many things about phase 4
and the upcoming phase 5 as well and he
stated that as you may know Emily Blunt
is going to be in the upcoming Disney
film Jungle Cruise that's coming out in
July of this year and while she was
filming she met with Marvel Studios and
she met with Marvel Studios about a role
in an upcoming film and this doesn't
come as that big of a surprise as Disney
owns Marvel Studios and Jungle Cruise is
a Disney movie the studios are obviously
very close so the fact that Marvel
Studios again owned by Disney would take
Emily Blunt while she's filming Jungle
Cruise
and talk to her about an upcoming role
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe isn't
that big of a surprise but the big
question of course is what role were
they talking to her about and what movie
would this character be appearing in
well there are three characters that she
is most likely to play in the MCU the
first one of course being Sue Storm the
Invisible Woman of the Fantastic Four
now as I mentioned all of the fans want
this to happen but it would actually be
a really good fit for her and not to
mention that if they cast her as The
Invisible Woman they will most likely
cast her husband as mr. fantastic and
this is pretty much the best case
scenario for fans as they probably would
be pretty pissed off as she was cast as
somebody else however the report says
that Emily Blunt met with Marvel Studios
to talk about an upcoming film now the
Fantastic Four may be a little bit away
coming in Phase five however their
introduction could come in phase four
not a full-out Fantastic Four movie in
phase four but an introduction to the
MCU in phase four and the most likely
fit for this would be one of two movies
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness or ant-man three
Mikey Sutton an insider and leaker and
the community has recently revealed that
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to introduce the
Illuminati the Illuminati in Marvel
Comics was a secret organization
comprised of several of the world's most
powerful superheroes the sorceress
supreme Doctor Strange Black Bolt king
of the Inhumans Charles Xavier founder
of the x-men and mutant rights activist
Namor the Submariner and of course the
king of Atlantis Iron Man Tony Stark one
of the founding members of the Avengers
and mr. fantastic Reed Richards now of
course it is possible that if the
Illuminati are introduced in Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness
that they switch mr. fantastic for Sue
Storm played by Emily Blunt
or they could even have both her and her
husband show up for a meeting to talk
about the Illuminati we could get a
post-credits seems similar to an
Avengers initiative with Nick Fury
Doctor Strange could say I'm here to
talk to you about the Illuminati but
there's also a possibility that she
could be appearing in Ant Man 3 in
ant-man and the wasp we were briefly
shown a quantum city inside of the
quantum realm and the director and Kevin
Feige have said that this is going to be
a very important part of the MCU and
since Avengers in game didn't explore
the quantum city like we thought it was
going to ant-man 3 most definitely will
and there actually is a good chance that
the Fantastic Four could be in this
quantum city if you're not aware in the
comics the Fantastic Four have a pretty
big connection to the quantum realm or
the Microverse as it is called in the
comics in one of the earliest battles
between the Fantastic Four and Doctor
Doom Doctor Doom gets sent to the
quantum realm or again the Microverse
Doctor Doom ends up conquering a city
inside of the multiverse and the
Fantastic Four follow him in once the
Fantastic Four go inside of the quantum
realm Doctor Doom traps them there and
it's actually ant-man that comes and
rescues them then they fight together
and they defeat Doctor Doom making him
flee from the quantum realm and they
then follow him so as you can see here
the Fantastic Four do have a connection
to ant-man and the quantum realm and
ant-man 3 is already confirmed to be
coming in phase 5 so the fact that Emily
Blunt has met with Marvel Studios about
an upcoming film means that she can
still play Sue Storm because there is a
possibility that Sue Storm the Invisible
Woman could show up in phase 4 or early
phase 5 now at the end of the day Marvel
does know exactly what they're doing and
although they do listen to fans they
will never hire someone just based off
of what the fans want the actors have to
be a good fit for the part and so far
the casting Department over at Marvel
Studios has done an absolutely
incredible job now it does seem like
Emily Blunt and her husband John
Krasinski are pretty much perfect for
the roles of Sue Storm The Invisible
Woman and Reed Richards mr. fantastic
however of course there are other roles
that Emily Blunt could play in fact
recently it's been announced that Clea
is going to be making her debut in
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness and the casting call for Clea is
a perfect description of Emily Blunt the
casting call says that they're looking
for an actress in her late 20s to early
40s to play the part and are looking to
find somebody with leading lady
qualities right now Emily Blunt is
currently 36 years old which obviously
is between late 20s and early 40s and if
they're looking for somebody with a
leading lady qualities she certainly has
those all you have to do is take a look
at her in the edge of tomorrow The
Adjustment Bureau looper and a quiet
place and Clea is going to be a major
part and Doctor Strange in the multi
of madness and will most likely be dr.
Strange's new love interest and in the
comics dr. strange and Clea are actually
married so she's going to be a big part
in multiverse of madness but she'll
probably stay around in the MCU for some
time and if you're talking about an
upcoming movie dr. strange in the
multiverse of madness is upcoming in
phase four and the fact that they have
already been casting for multiverse of
madness already and are currently
casting lines up pretty well with her
speaking to Marvel Studios during the
filming of Jungle Cruise since that just
finished so it seems like there could be
a high possibility that the role that
Marvel Studios was speaking to her about
could have been Clea but let's not
forget the one franchise that is going
to be coming to the MCU soon that has a
ton of very powerful female superheroes
the x-men there are so many different
women of x-men that Emily Blunt could be
talking to Marvel Studios about plane
she could be playing Jean Grey after all
she has been in movies where she's had
red hair and Marvel is definitely going
to be recasting all of the x-men that
are going to be introduced into the MCU
and it would be even more awesome if her
husband John Krasinski would play
Cyclops but that's just me fan casting
but another x-men that she could be
playing is Emma Frost and I actually
think that she would be a really good
candidate to play this character Emma
Frost is one of the most powerful x-men
to ever exist she has two powers and one
of course is to turn herself into an
organic flexible diamond form which
pretty much makes her invulnerable but
she also happens to be one of the most
strongest telepaths in the x-men
universe on par with Professor X himself
she can use her telepathy to control any
situation and manipulate anything that
she wants and it's her telepathic
abilities that make her easily one of
the strongest x-men but if Marvel
Studios is going to go the route of
introducing new x-men that we haven't
really seen before she could be playing
Hope Summers hope might be the most
powerful mutant ever created hope is an
omega-level mutant who has the ability
to mimic the powers of anyone near her
in their most powerful form so if you're
looking to introduce one of the most
awesome and powerful x-men in the
universe and you're looking for an
awesome actor to play her Emily Blunt
definitely fits the part now at the end
of the day Marvel talks to a lot of
different actors about a lot of
different roles Kevin
the president of Marvel Studios has
admitted to meeting with many actors
about many different roles he said that
he met with Jake Gyllenhaal about a
number of films until they finally found
spider-man far from Holmes Mysterio and
it was a perfect fit for him they
finally cast him the same thing has
currently been happening with Keanu
Reeves Kevin Feige said that they meet
with Keanu Reeves about every single MCU
movie they make they meet with him about
certain roles for the movies that he
could possibly play and be a good fit
for unfortunately they haven't found
that perfect role for him yet so he
hasn't been cast as anything in the MCU
but right now we know that Emily Blunt
is meeting with Marvel Studios for a
role in the MCU there are plenty of
perfect roles that Emily Blunt could
play in the MCU but let's hope she
actually does end up playing Sue Storm
it's definitely what the fans want and
then her husband could come in and play
mr. fantastic as well but is this
something that you would want let me
know what role you would like to see
Emily Blunt plane and the MCU would you
like to see her as Sue's storm The
Invisible Woman in the Fantastic Four
would you like to see her as an x-men or
what other role would you like to see
her in let me know in the comments down
below don't forget to like this video
and subscribe with notifications turned
on so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 if
the winner gets to choose and I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers don't forget
to follow me on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff